das war ein donnerschlag kaum erwartet
insgeheim befürchtet von den partei- und
fraktionsspitzen der union volker kauder
und der liegt ralph brinkhaus bei der
neuwahl zum fraktionsvorsitz dieser
denkzettel gilt vor allem der kanzlerin
die folgen sind momentan unabsehbar
schwere schlappe merkels mann ist
abgewählt unser thema in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer bei
uns war eine gäste hier im studio
wir haben holstein ist chefreporter den
innenpolitiker der bild am sonntag herr
kretschmar kommunikations und
politikberater
sie haben die spd im bundestagswahlkampf
2013 beraten von 290 bis 2021 auch
mitglied im juso bundesvorstand
zeitweise unter der vorsitzenden andrea
nahles und ich hatte einmal war und
politik forscher geschäftsführer von
policy makers gesellschaft für politik
forschung und politikberatung für auch
mal bei infratest dimap die das
demoskopische institut das für die ard
arbeitet und alexander kissler ist bei
uns ressortleiter salon beim magazin
cicero
als erstes wollen wir wissen was die
bundeskanzlerin zu all dem sagt was da
heute nachmittag um 16 uhr 47 verkündet
worden ist das ist eine stunde der
demokratie in der gibt es auch
niederlagen und da gibt es auch nichts
zu beschönigen ja da gibt es nichts zu
beschönigen vorstand und eine stunde der
demokratie was auch noch gestern ist ja
noch sacharbeit angekündigt worden in
der koalition nach all dem was um
hans-georg maßen da passiert ist
an dieser arbeit ist jetzt zunächst mal
wohl nicht zu denken
sie ist ja heute wieder angekündigt
worden vom neuen fraktionsvorsitzenden
insofern können wir immer noch weiter
hoffen aber in der tat das war heute was
womit glaube ich die allerwenigsten
gerechnet haben
ich glaube nicht einmal herr brinkhaus
selbst wenn man seine gesichtszüge
richtig gedeutet hat hatte damit
gerechnet und für die kanzlerin ist es
natürlich ein schwerer schlag
das hat man auch bei diesem statement
gesehen interessant ist ja was sie noch
vorhergesagt hat sie hat nämlich gesagt
ich biete ihnen gute zusammenarbeit an
es hat mich ein bisschen an die
formulierung erinnert die sie verwandt
hat als die donald trump zum wahlsieg
gratuliert hat also sie ist auch nicht
mit ihnen gemeinsam vor die presse
getreten
das da merkte man ja anders da kannst du
sie hört sich an ihren neuen
fraktionschef noch gewöhnen müssen
herr kessler trotz allem was heute
passiert ist
neuwahlen werden jetzt allerdings gift
für beide oder für alle drei
koalitionsparteien
wir haben eine koalition die ja in der
bevölkerung auf immer weniger zustimmung
trifft die letzte umfrage die ich kenne
von gestern 24 prozent hätten noch
vertrauen in die arbeit von cdu csu und
spd wir haben bundestags landtagswahlen
vor uns mit desaströsen demoskopie
ergebnissen
schlimmer noch als bayern finde ich
eigentlich hessen wo ein drittel der
stimmen oder 10% prozentpunkte weniger
für die cdu am balken stehen das heißt
jeder der jetzt neuwahlen will ich vom
zaun bricht der muss wissen dass er
eventuell in die opposition geht unter
politiker immer mit der verteilung von
öffentlicher macht zu tun hat halte ich
es für ausgeschlossen dass noch vor
jahresende jemand diesen schritt wagt
probleme vom zaun brechen
herr hilmer das war ja ganz schön kühn
von der bundestags mannschaft der union
ihren steuermann so kurz vor
landtagswahlen von bott zu jagen
goutiert dass sie haben lange erfahrung
als wahlforscher gut hier der wähler so
etwas oder wendet er sich mit grausen ab
die frage ist ja aber das überhaupt im
hinterkopf der abgeordneten als sie
heute entschieden haben
ich glaube dieses ereignis ist dass die
wähler anbetrifft nicht ganz so wichtig
wie die ereignisse zuvor und maßen das
war glaube ich eine spur problematischer
das ist eher eine innerparteiliche krise
die jetzt stattfindet die nach außen
nicht so wirkt allerdings eins ist auch
klar dass wird system wähler und
wählerinnen nicht her völlig entgangen
sein
das bedeutet natürlich eine schwächung
der bundeskanzlerin und das in der
situation wo es natürlich gerade heute
führung bräuchte ist die führung heute
geschwächt das ist nicht unbedingt ein
gutes zeichen auch nicht für die beiden
landtagswahlen der sich neben der
koalitionäre egal ob jetzt csu der cdu
spd ist immer dabei und die wahlen
werden jetzt sicherlich nochmal ein
stückchen schwieriger werden
zumal der fraktion zahl der cdu/csu wo
all das passiert es ist genug gefährt 20
meter weg vom fraktionssaal der es für
die oben auf der fraktionsebene nachdem
das ergebnis bekannt gegeben wurde kam
eine doch relativ erleichtert aussehen
der andrea nahles aus und das zu
kommentieren
sie sprachen von einem aufstand gegen
merkel andererseits hat sie das
vielleicht auch bedauerte mit volker
kauder konnte sie ja ganz gut diese
erleichterung die im gesicht von anklam
von andrea nahles stand hat das auch
damit zu tun dass sie jetzt das gefühl
hat den nächsten tagen steht sie nicht
im mittelpunkt der medien
berichterstattung und kann vielleicht
nachts ab und zu mal durchschlafen
ich glaube es ist heute endgültig eines
deutlich geworden dass die krise dieser
regierung viel mit der krise der union
zu tun hat und mit den problemen einer
partei die zwischen zwei polen sich neu
ausrichten muss und das in einer
situation wo sie an der macht ist und
das ist vielleicht in den
auseinandersetzungen der letzten wochen
um herrn maßen nicht so deutlich
geworden und ist jetzt wieder etwas
klarer auf den tischen
gestern haben ja auch eher so etwas wie
eine premiere erlebt gestern morgen vor
beginn der präsidiumssitzung der cdu die
bundeskanzlerin hat ein weitergehendes
fehler ein geständnis live vor den
kameras von sich gegeben das hat er
jetzt aber auch nichts mehr genutzt
wenn man das ergebnis des heutigen tages
an sie in der tat aber ich glaube auch
dass diese entschuldigung zu einem zu
einem teil davon motiviert war dass sie
die reihen noch mal schließen wollte mit
blick auf die abstimmung in der fraktion
heute
man muss aber fairerweise dazusagen ich
glaube es war auch zu einem großen teil
dadurch motiviert dass sie tatsächlich
der ansicht war dass man mit dieser
ersten entscheidung zur causa maßen dass
man da einen fehler gemacht hatte ich
hatte gehört dass sie dass sie nicht
erst abgewartet hat bis andrea nahles
sich telefonisch und dann per brief an
siehe sowohl sie als auch als seehofer
gewandt hat sondern dass sie vorher
schon von sich aus horst seehofer
angesprochen hat und mit ihm darüber
gesprochen hat diese dass man diese
entscheidung ihn zum staatssekretär zu
befördern
dass man die revidieren
das war natürlich wenig zu sagen
formulierungen die er schon sehr tief
blicken lässt also ich hab jetzt noch
mal angeschaut sie sagt ich habe zu
wenig anders gedacht was die menschen zu
recht bewegt als eine bundeskanzlerin
die sagt ich habe das was die menschen
also das volk die bürger bewegt habe ich
nicht mehr richtig im blick und heute
haben wir gesehen sie hat offenbar auch
die fraktion nicht mehr richtig im blick
in ihre mehrheitsverhältnissen das hat
das gespür offenbar verloren
für das volk das sie repräsentiert und
auch für weite teile ihrer eigenen
fraktion
es ist die große frage auf welcher basis
willst überhaupt weiter regieren
versagten die antennen der kanzlerin da
jetzt nicht nur was diese formulierung
angeht sie hat nicht so richtig
wahrgenommen was recht die bevölkerung
bewegt sondern auch die antennen
gegenüber dem was die partei und was die
fraktion bewegt denn man kann sie ja
positiv sagen immerhin es jetzt gemerkt
also das war ja nicht immer so es gab ja
entscheidungen die bis heute eben sehr
strittig sind und wo eben dieses mega
kult bis heute ausgeblieben ist
insofern ist es eine neuerung eine wie
ich finde sehr bemerkenswerte
veränderung der kanzlerin und die kann
durchaus die grundlage dafür sein dass
eben das wofür eigentlich die große die
dritte große koalition jetzt stehen
müsste nämlich ein großes überschrift
wir haben verstanden was eigentlich sich
durch zählt in die in dem ein
bildungspapier von union die die un je
so was sich durch zieht im
koalitionsvertrag
was sogar im 40 punkte masterplan von
seehofer drin ist nämlich der versuch
sozusagen das was alle drei
volksparteien zerreißt diese
polarisierung um die migrationspolitik
und einem hut zu bringen nämlich die
willkommens politik die ja immer noch
sehr stark ist diese kultur die in
deutschland sehr stark ausgeprägt ist
aber eben auch die wachsenden sorgen und
das kann durchaus auch dazu führen dass
auch die kanzlerin sich da ein bisschen
bewegt und versucht diesen bereich der
eben sehr stark zur schwächung aller
drei parteien beigetragen hat jetzt zu
einem verträglichen ende zu führen auf
jeden fall wäre das jetzt denke ich eine
der zentralen sache aufgaben neben der
vielen anderen die natürlichen drang
also eine art warnschuss auch vor den
bug aber nochmal zu dem was da am
nachmittag passiert ist
wer war das eigentlich wem hat trinkaus
den sieg zu verdanken
man hatte ja gehört das kann von einer
panne eine abstimmungspanne bis hin zu
einer gezielten niederlage die geplant
war angela merkel eine niederlage
beizubringen alles gewesen sein also an
eine panne glaube ich auf keinen fall
ich finde auch dazu ist das ergebnis zu
eindeutig 125 212 ist ja nicht so als ob
eine 22 stimmen vorsprung gewonnen hätte
ich gehe davon aus dass die viele aus
der csu für ihn gestimmt haben und
vielleicht auch viele aus der cdu die
eigentlich den moment so gar nicht für
gekommen hielten jetzt schon einen
wechsel an der fraktionsspitze oder
jetzt schon ein zeichen der erneuerung
zu setzen aber da hatte sich ebenso viel
unmut angestaut und die dritte gruppe
ist das ist jetzt auch viele abgeordnete
neu in den bundestag gekommen und gerade
in der jungen gruppe gibt es auch sehr
viel sage ich jetzt mal widerstandsgeist
und das alles hat so eine dynamik
entfacht das eben die leute vorher
beziehungsweise was man vorher gehört
ein war die meisten haben selbst nicht
geglaubt selbst die die es geschafft
haben aber hat dann soviel
unbotmäßigkeit kennt man eigentlich nur
von der spd
die da auf diesem gebiet sehr viel mehr
schon im laufe der parteigeschichte
hingekriegt hat da können manche
ehemalige parteivorsitzende ein lied
davon singen
es ist jetzt eine forderung erhoben
worden zugegebener weise aus der
opposition oder gibt es vielleicht auch
bei der spd dass angela merkel jetzt am
besten die vertrauensfrage stellen
sollte ist das ein brauchbares
instrument die koalition also
einschließlich spd dann auch wieder
sozusagen zu schließen um sich zu
scharen um sicherzugehen dass es jetzt
tatsächlich weitergeht und dass diese
zentrifugalen kräfte nicht weiter
stärker werden ehrlich gesagt ich glaube
nicht dass es dafür in der jetzigen
situation eine ernste veranlassung gibt
weil die vertrauensfrage ist ja
schon für eine situation gedacht in der
ernste zweifel daran bestehen dass
angela merkel ihre politik durchsetzen
kann trinkhaus steht nicht für die
polarisierung zwingend in der union er
steht für ein eigenes profil das finde
ich das interessante dass ihnen glaube
ich sehr viele gewählt haben die
eigentlich einen schritt in die spd zu
beginn dieser koalition begann hat
nämlich mit andrea nahles jemanden an
die spitze von partei und fraktion zu
stellen denn nicht in die
kabinettsdisziplin eingebunden ist die
idee dabei oder kakao da auch nicht ja
gut aber volker kauder wissen wir alle
waren natürlich schon ein sehr treuer
gefolgsmann der bundeskanzlerin
dann haben wir das letzte mal einen von
angela merkel abweichendes wort von
volker kauder gehört ich kann mich nicht
erinnern daran so das heißt die idee die
dahinter steckt ist ja zu sagen wenn wir
schon zusammen regieren dann müssen die
parteien trotzdem ein profil entwickeln
und dieses profil zeigen und das finde
ich spannend ist kann tatsächlich eine
chance sein dass mit brinkhaus jetzt
jemand die fraktion führt der dieses
profil ein stückweit zeigen kann ohne
zwingend an und staunten den konflikt
mit angela merkels aber jubeln kann die
spd eigentlich nicht über brinkhaus und
zwar inhaltlich nicht denn er ist
gläubig ehren marktliberaler und hat ja
schon angekündigt auch im vorfeld der
wahl also wenn er gewählt wird
man kann nicht alle probleme in der
gesellschaft mit sozialleistungen zu
schützen das camp einem sozialdemokrat
nie über die lippen ist da schon eine
mögliche auch eine profilierung der
union angesagt die sich gleichzeitig ein
bisschen von der spd absetzt und es auch
schwieriger macht innerhalb der
koalition zu einer einigung in
verschiedenen sachfragen zu kommen denn
wir erleben doch in den letzten wochen
jenseits sitzen mal der der
auseinandersetzung die wir um maßen und
ähnliches hatten wo sozusagen immer
wieder die koalition gewackelt hat aber
wir leben doch seitens der spd finde ich
einen relativ klaren kurs nämlich zu
sagen wir benennen das was wir politisch
wollen und wir wissen dass wir davon ab
schichten müssen in der frage was wir
mit dieser koalition tun können und ich
glaube dass das auch der union gut tun
würde zu sagen was ist eigentlich der
kurs den wir fahren wollen jenseits
sozusagen eines merkel
kompromisses und und die chance besteht
schon und wenn das gelingt und die
beteiligten miteinander des
vertrauensvollen managen können kann es
am ende sogar eine stabilisierung dieser
situation bedeutet ich jetzt sein das
ist schon sehr optimistisch dass wir
sagen hier die spd stünde für eine
einheitliche linie also wir lesen alle
die interviews von herrn gabriel die
ständigen twitter botschaften von herrn
kevin kühnert also das ist überhaupt
keine einheitliche linie fand ich da ist
die regionalpartei die bundes partei die
position zur flüchtlingspolitik sind
sehr sehr zerrissen also ich glaube bei
all ihre liebe zur juso vergangenheit
man kann jetzt nicht den jetzigen
zustand der spd bei 16 17 als vorbild
für eine erneuerung natürlich ansteht
von cdu und csu nehmen da es geht gar
nicht darum zu sagen dass die das spd
geeint wäre nur die frage ist ja
entwickelt sich ein profil jenseits der
der koalition
die aufgabe muss sie lösen sonst wird
sich in dieser koalition unternehmen sie
haben gerade die drei gruppen der
hauptverdächtigen für die
abstimmungsniederlage von volker kauder
genannt gibt es in der union einfach
allzu viele die eine schwächung der
kanzlerin billigend in kauf nehmen
gerade in der jetzigen situation das
muss man aus diesem ergebnis in der tat
schließen ich glaube aber dass da
verschiedene faktoren zusammen kann also
das eines war sicherlich ein denkzettel
für angela merkel ich glaube aber das
zweite und das darf man nicht vergessen
dass es eben auch großen unmut über
volker kauder gab der die fraktion so
lange geführt
ihm werfen viele vor ihr nach einer gut
am ende zumindest am ende nach
gutsherrenart geführt er war sehr
holprig die widerstände wunder
weggebügelt und das hat sich dann eben
auch da war angebrochen das kann man ja
aber nicht sozusagen zu schreiben ich
mal was bedeutet das eigentlich für die
schwesterpartei der cdu die csu die die
csu diese diese niederlage von volker
kauder aber natürlich dann in erster
linie auch angela merkel
das zumindest neue der focus ein
bisschen stärker auf die schwesterpartei
cdu gerichtet ist denn zuletzt stand er
hat auch die csu bisher stark unter
druck
das ist sicherlich aus sicht der csu
jetzt nicht das schlechteste
sozusagen die csu zumindest eben
bayerische komponente söder die jetzt
unmittelbar vor landtagswahlen stehen ja
so als eben ein kontrollierendes
momentan vielleicht wahrzunehmen was ja
zuletzt nicht unbedingt der fall war
ich denke dass es auch die möglichkeit
bietet eben diesen formelkompromiss der
gefunden wurde in vielerlei bereichen zu
einem realen kompromiss dann zu formen
ob das wirklich mit den handelnden
personen möglich ist muss man mal
abwarten denn da scheint sie nun
tatsächlich nach wie vor ziemliche
probleme zu geben zwischen merkel und
seehofer und die sind jetzt nicht aus
der welt geschaffen die sie mit
sicherheit immer noch da aber zumindest
kann die csu jetzt einigermaßen beruhigt
er in den wahlkampf geben weil sie jetzt
nicht mehr nur als das unruhe stiften im
moment innerhalb der koalition wäre
heute horst seehofer heute abend in
münchen würde entspannt aufs oktoberfest
gehen können
das hast du die csu ist das im moment
eine etwas solider als seehofer würde
ich jetzt mal und hoffe hat ja auch für
kauder geworden also ist ja auch ein
teil seiner niederlage ja auch nicht
vergessen ist ja nicht so dass er für
auf den jetzigen sieger gesetzt hat das
problem war glaube ich nach den allem
was wir hören aus den sitzungen dass
frau merkel ihr plädoyer für kauder
letzten endes auch das argument
zugespitzt hat im ried nicht die pferde
wechseln schwierige zeiten draußen wir
müssen zusammenhalten kontinuität
schlägt aufbruch und jetzt sehen wir
innerhalb der cdu csu fraktion es ist
aufbruch möglich und das ist das signal
von heute das auch über die fraktion
hinaus dringt auch bei schwierigen
zeiten muss es möglich sein ein neues
personal durch eine neue programmatik in
verantwortungsvolle position zu sitzen
zu setzen was das heißt für den
bundestag für die bundeskanzlerin für
die parteispitze werden wir noch sehen
aber das signal ist gesetzt wechsel ist
machbar
es war der tag an dem die cdu
insbesondere die cdu gelernt hat dass
man eine wahl haben kann eine echte wenn
man eben entsprechend viel mut
aufbringen obwohl die kannst du dir
sagte sie tragen mich alle
das ist ja wir haben sich glaube ich
hier getötet dieser zeitpunkt wäre der
falsche für einen wechsel wird sie vor
der wahl gesagt also dass sie hat also
ganz persönlich auch noch mal gegen
horst seehofer würde ich allerdings
widersprechen wollen ja also er hat es
war ja auch überraschen dass er da in
der fraktions- und weise war jetzt nicht
unbedingt damit gerechnet worden dass er
bekommt aber er war dann da und er hat
auch noch mal von einer kauder
gesprochen dann ist es für ihn natürlich
auch eine niederlage
andererseits sucht er ja auch
gelegenheiten um in opposition zu angela
merkels geben insofern denke ich er hat
es mit einem wahrscheinlich mit einem
lachenden und einem weinenden auge heute
gesehen wenn man die frage andrea nahles
ist das für sie ist jetzt eine art
atempause wird sich vielleicht auch
sogar nutzen ist ja selbst unter
beschuss gestanden dass sie sagt also
ich muss jetzt erst mal im eigenen laden
klarkommen und das wäre vielleicht ohne
diese niederlage von volker kauder nicht
möglich gewesen weil sie dann er selbst
im öffentlichen fokus stand und die
diskussion der spd ist nicht beendet
über ihr verhalten in sachen maßen
ich glaube sie hat sie schon beruhigt
aber es wäre ihr zu empfehlen der der
punkt ist aber glaube ich noch noch ein
stück weiter zu fassen weil ich finde
die letzten tage heute inklusive zeigen
dass ein neuer führungsstil in den
regierungs koalition notwendig ist und
das ist auch erste anzeichen dafür gibt
dass dieser neue führungsstils sozusagen
sich sich durchsetzt wir leben in einer
zeit in der politik nicht mehr mit den
gewissheiten des durchregierens
funktioniert weil das fahrwasser
unruhiger ist weil wir über hoch
kontroverse themen diskutieren weil bis
in die union hinein die frage europa
versus national
sein kontrovers diskutiert wird und da
muss man auf einen politikstil wesel
setzen der mehr zuhört der mehr
profiliert der mehr erklärt und
erläutert
und ich habe den eindruck dass sowohl
die aussage von andrea nahles ich habe
mich geirrt und wir müssen eine eine
umkehr wende machen als auch die
entscheidung der fraktion heute für
jemanden der zumindest versprochen hat
dass er für ein eigenes profil sorgen
will
in diese richtung weisen und eine chance
insofern auch darstellen können ob beide
die nutzen werden wir sehen
gegen den jetzt die innerparteilichen
angriffe auf merkel erst richtig los die
gegner blut geleckt ihr
selbstverständlich ich meine was ist das
entscheidende herrschaftsinstrument in
einer machtmaschine wie der cdu macht
macht verteilen können macht
akkumulieren über übermacht bestimmen
können sie hat offenbar nicht mehr
genügend macht in der hand um jene die
gegen sie aufbegehren still zu halten
also die listen platzvergabe oder die
anderen vorsitz posten die sie vergeben
kann sind offenbar nicht mehr stark
genug um in eine trudelnde cdu hinein
koalitionskräfte bindekräfte an sie zu
entwickeln dh die ablehnung die wächst
außerhalb des blasen raumschiffs berlin
ist so groß geworden dass auch innerhalb
die fliehkräfte zugenommen haben das
heißt wir sehen dass nun die
aufsplitterung der gesellschaft die wir
nicht zuletzt aufgrund der märkischen
migrationspolitik erleben zur
aufsplitterung innerhalb der partei
führt die maßgeblich diese politik zu
verantworten hat das ist eigentlich ein
normaler fast ein gesunder zustand
möchte ich sagen vorgang die frage ist
nur ob wirklich frau merkel sich nur
empfinden kann ob sie ihre
willkommenskultur ansatzweise
relativieren kann ob sie ihren
politikstil dass merkel wie man es nennt
ändern kann
ich glaube das sind große fragen ob sie
sich wirklich neu erfinden will
hat man denn nimmt denn die bevölkerung
auch wahr dass unter diesen beiden
themen immigrationspolitik also vor der
sommerpause dieser dieser streit
zwischen den unionsschwestern und dann
die auseinandersetzung um den
verfassungsschutz präsidenten das
unterhalb dieser in der öffentlichkeit
so der vorangestellten diskussionen ja
eigentlich auch tatsächlich in der
regierungsarbeit schon einiges passiert
ist stichwort kita stichwort pflege
es ist auch die eine rente rentengesetz
ein neues auf den weg gebracht worden
eigentlich alles das was an sachpolitik
der angekündigten es ist ja zum teil
auch schon passiert ist es nicht so dass
nichts passiert ist wie wird das
eigentlich wahrgenommen wird das war
nicht goutiert dass man sagt man ja auch
einiges gemacht was wir angekündigt
haben sie schon bestehen natürlich denn
in der tat ist sind eine ganze reihe von
wichtigen politischen entscheidungen
auch und gerade in der migrationspolitik
gefallen die dazu geeignet wären
zumindest der eben das ganze ein
bisschen zu beruhigen und dann auch
wieder den fokus zu anderen sachthemen
zu lenken aber es wurde ja wie lange wir
hin natürlich die kommunikationspolitik
der das war ja das eigentliche problem
das man sich eben um punkte dann streckt
gerade übernimmt 40 punkte masterplan
und man sich sagt das kann man sich also
leicht vorher mal klären
das sind auch petitessen eigentlich und
daraus eine veritable koalitionskrise
dann zu kreieren das zweite dann mit
maßen wieder das sind eigentlich keine
politischen grundfragen das sind keine
dieser fragen jetzt im grundsätzlichen
bereich sondern sind wirklich nur
kommunalwahlen vermöbelt man sich
gegenseitig auf zwei gebieten selber
gesagt petitessen das bedarf ja nur
wenige dutzend migranten dieses problem
im juli und jetzt um den
verfassungsschutz präsidenten das
nachgeordnete behörde ist ein beamter
kann politiker das hätte man in der tat
die er wesentlich schneller über die
bühne bringen können trotzdem hat man
sich da mit leidenschaft zerfleischt
woran liegt das
beide sind immer noch nicht die erste
die die nicht ausgetragenen konflikte
vor allem zwischen merkel und seehofer
die möglicherweise eben danach den
bayern war dann ein gewisses ende finden
das ist zumindest die hoffnung denn ich
glaube ich das ist die größte hürde der
zeit zurück zur sachpolitik das eben die
formen ja schon da sind entscheidungen
sind daran der koalitionsvertrag ist da
eine ganze reihe von pumpen sind ja
vorhanden da sind sich die
koalitionspartner völlig einig aber in
detailfragen verhält hat man sich immer
wieder und setzt diese einigung dann
aufs spiel
ich finde es auch auf der anderen seite
sehr positiv dass eben die dissonante
die die unterschiede dann auch der
beiden parteien oder der treibt
kann jetzt wieder ein bisschen
deutlicher werden könnte bringt man
steht zumindest eben für
wirtschaftsliberale hre möglicherweise
auch für eine konservativere
positionierung der cdu
das könnte dann auch durchaus eben zu
einer stabilisierung der union der der
koalition führen denn man hat sich ja
eigentlich geeinigt auf dem programm
eben bis zumindest zum nächsten jahr
herbst 2009 10
bis dahin sollte es reichen wenn man
sich eben auf die sachpolitik jetzt
wirklich konzentrieren könnte dann kann
man noch mal das ganze revue passieren
lassen und dann können die beiden
parteien in ihren neuen konstellationen
die union bereits sozusagen die letzte
partei die sich jetzt zumindest
partiellen eine neue führung gegeben hat
die anderen sind ja voran marschierte
dann kann man sich dann überlegen ob das
noch für weitere zwei jahre trägt es
gibt ja kurzfristiges ungemach und es
gibt auch längerfristig sich ankündigen
das ungemach sie haben vom herbst 2009
10 gesprochen und meinen wahrscheinlich
so genannten soll bruch den sich die spd
da verordnet hat nach zwei jahren die
revisionsklage wir wollen wir eigentlich
überhaupt noch mit der union eine
koalition weiterführen das stellen sich
ja jetzt schon viele und haben eine
klare antwort dazu wie sie die chancen
dass es danach weitergeht jetzt auch
durch die ereignisse der letzten wochen
ist da so viel porzellan zerschlagen
worden dass es für andrea nahles und
auch für olaf scholz sehr schwer werden
wird da die mehrheit der fraktion die
partei hat er ja bei der spd auch noch
etwas mitzubestimmen
da nochmal hinter sich zu versammeln
sagen wir machen diese koalition bis
2021 weiter wenn die anderen
ja die andere voraus sondern auch
stimmen aber es sind auch thema gleichen
die die koalition und dass das regieren
kritisieren ich habe nicht den eindruck
dass ist wirklich verschiebungen in den
mehrheitsverhältnissen in der
sozialdemokratie gibt und ich bin ganz
bei herrn kessler die die kernfrage ist
auch wird in zwölf monaten die situation
design das ist der spd nutzt diese
koalition zu brechen und dieses
rechenspiel wird meines erachtens nach
nicht aufgehen
ich glaube an einen ganz anderen
zeitpunkt zu dem die die die fliehkräfte
groß werden nach der eu-präsidentschaft
2020 mit 2020 muss angela merkel die
frage der nach machtnachfolge einleiten
parteivorsitz abgeben und und sozusagen
irgendwann ja auch auf die strecke
kommen zu erklären wie wie wie ihre
nachfolger aussehen soll und das ist der
moment wo die fliehkräfte die wir heute
haben durchblitzen sehen dann richtig
losgehen und insofern glaube ich eher
dass wir uns genau zwei jahren hier
sitzen werden gibt es ja vielleicht noch
ein anderes ereignis das mit dem europa
was zu tun nämlich die wahl zum
europäischen parlament im mai nächsten
jahres ist immer war davon aus dass zum
beispiel die spd bei dieser wahl
abschmieren würde wäre das dann auch
irgendwann dass es dann sagt jetzt uns
nützt die teilnahme das ist ja auch eine
sozusagen eine art denkzettel oder
abrechnung mit der regierungspolitik in
berlin wenn die parteien dazu europawahl
antreten das ist jetzt diese diese
mitgliedschaft in der groko die nützt
uns nichts mehr jetzt dann nicht lieber
ein ende mit schrecken als ein schrecken
ohne ende könnte das nicht schon viel
früher passieren
die stimmen wird es geben gar keine
frage
neulich ich sehe nicht dass sie über
neue argumente verfügen gegenüber der
der situation als die spd sich
entschieden hat und insofern glaube ich
wir werden die gespaltenheit die ja auch
schon angesprochen war werden wir weiter
erleben und die verläuft ungefähr ein
drittel zwei drittel und das reicht
üblicherweise mit demokratie also ich
nehme schon eine geänderte atmosphäre in
der spd war und ich glaube auch nicht
dass ich die revisionsklausel sein wird
die da die große frage in den raum
stellen
in einer phase der stabilität besprochen
wird dann gibt es ja keinen anlass zu
sagen jetzt kündigen wir die
zusammenarbeit auf da wird das würde der
wähler nicht goutieren
aber ich finde jetzt die causa maßen hat
doch gezeigt dass es da brodelt und es
waren viele haben sich zu wort gemeldet
oder auch hinter den kulissen in vielen
gesprächen die damals dafür gestimmt
haben dass man in die große koalition
eintritt und ich glaube das große
problem der spd ist dass sie immer mehr
dämmert dass sie egal in welcher egal
wie sie sich verhält in der großen
koalition dass sie keinen blumentopf
damit gewinnen kann
in der letzten legislatur war sie sehr
geschmeidig als koalitionspartner ist
hat sich für sie nicht ausgezahlt in
dieser legislatur hat sie jetzt versucht
ein bisschen mehr front zu machen ist ja
auch bei maßen sehr schnell sehr
aggressiv vorgegangen
es hat sich für sie nicht ausgezahlt wir
haben zwei landtagswahlen anstehen wo
die spd deutliche verluste wohl
hinnehmen wird
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass diese
frage dann doch deutlich früher im raum
steht und die europawahlen sind
letztendlich glaube ich da nicht so
erheblich aus der sicht ist deutschland
die unsicherheitsfaktoren in der groko
die waren ja am anfang so ein bisschen
spd durch die geburtswehen beim eintritt
in die große koalition
daneben der selbstfindungsprozess von
horst seehofer auf unterschiedlichen
ebenen und mit unterschiedlichen themen
wenn man das jetzt was heute nachmittag
in berlin passiert ist sieht sind die
sicherheitsrisiken für den bestand der
großen koalition jetzt auf alle drei
parteien einigermaßen gleichmäßig
verteilt dass man sie vorher auch schon
das hat das bundestagswahlergebnis
gezeigt dass alle drei gleichermaßen
verloren haben am schluss war es ja
sogar noch die csu das war sicherlich
das überraschendste umso deutlicher ist
dann die niederlage dann auch die
verluste zumindest eben ausgefallen
das ist nichts neues ich denke schon
dass die parteien sich eben
grundsätzlich gedanken machen müssen bei
der spd ist es natürlich so dass es
weniger die große koalition ist die
grundlage für ihre schwierigkeiten ist
sondern die gründe liegen glaube ich
schon weit tiefer das ist die
unfähigkeit der spd ihre zentrale
funktion weiter zu erfüllen eine klammer
zu sein zwischen liberalen bürgertum und
den einfachen arbeitnehmer die letztere
gruppe hat sie in den letzten jahren
schlicht dann einfach verloren aus den
verloren hat die sprache für diese leute
verloren und so lange sie diesen
anschluss nicht mehr schafften diese
wählerschaft sie erzählt zum teil an
fast schon aufgegeben
dann wird es auch schwierig sein für sie
wieder eben diese führende rolle in dem
linken parteienspektrum zu behaupten
dann wird sie sich in irgendeiner form
teil müssten mit grünen und mit der
linkspartei was er in bayern was sie in
manchen regionen der republik ja heute
schon der fall ist und sind von einer
linken mehrheit dann meilenweit entfernt
ist da im frühjahr im märz etwas aus der
not heraus weil auch jamaika ja nicht
einmal in ansätzen gescheitert ist aus
der not heraus etwas zusammen gezwungen
worden was eben nicht mehr zusammen
gehören nein ich finde es eigentlich das
war eine sehr konsequente und gute
entscheidungen weil die große koalition
hat uns sozusagen das eingebrockt womit
wir heute noch beschafft beschäftigt
sind diese polarisierung der
gesellschaft da gab sicherlich schon
ansätze vor das kann jetzt nicht völlig
über nacht aber der ausbruch war eben
dann im herbst der 2015
die große koalition hat sie in den
darauffolgenden jahren nicht geschafft
das einigermaßen im griff zu bekommen
sie hat im grunde genommen glaube ich
jetzt die richtigen schritte unternommen
um das eben zu befrieden um sozusagen
wieder weg von diesem hoch
emotionalisierenden thema
migrationspolitik hin zu anderen
sachthemen zu kommen
das sind eigentlich die chancen auch für
union und für spd dort eben zu
brillieren
dort liegt auch letztlich die die frage
der zukunft führen und deutsche und das
wieder erreichen ist glaube ich die
aufgabe das kann auch in den nächsten
jahr gelingen dann kann man sich nochmal
hinsetzen kann überlegen
der koalitionsvertrag trägt ja
eigentlich nur jetzt bis zum herbst 2009
10 danach müssen neue entscheidungen
gefällt werden man kann nicht zwei jahre
einfach nur sozusagen das entscheiden
was gerade anfällt
das muss schon auch eine regierung sein
die im ziel hat die 1 1 eine große idee
hat und die große überschrift dieser
jetzigen großen koalition ist wir haben
verstanden und wir müssen uns wieder so
hinkriegen dass wir wieder zur
klassischen politik zurückkommen hat
sich da im parteiensystem aber nicht
dorthin sehr viel
verschoben wir haben jahrzehnte lang
gelernt der bundesrepublik der sinn
einer partei die sich zur wahl stelle
ist möglichst viele stimmen zu kriegen
und dann politik zu gestalten kann man
am besten mit regierungsbeteiligung wenn
man sich jetzt heute ansieht wie sich
manche vor währungs beteiligung quasi
finden sie nicht an sich herankommen zu
lassen und vielleicht nur union und
grüne wirklich lust auf regieren haben
ist das auch eine ganz andere politische
kultur mit der wir jetzt ganz neue
umgehen müssen und ganz neu lernen
müssen wenn die macht der wird sie nicht
erringen
das ist völlig klar ich bin hier von
optimisten umgeben was die zukunft der
spd angeht ich sehe das ein bisschen
anders werden jetzt gerade eine umfrage
welche wähler von der letzten wahl
bereuen ihre wahlentscheidung am
stärksten da waren 44 prozent der spd
wähler wurden da genannt also 44 prozent
der spd wähler würden heute nicht mehr
die spd wählen die sie bereuen ist nicht
aber sie würden sie heute nicht mehr
wählen also wenn sagen warten fehler aus
heutiger sicht
ich glaube dass 44 prozent wäre ein
bisschen weniger noch 44 prozent sagen
ich würde sie heute nicht mehr wählen
von der wieder einmal 1 10 prozent bei
12 prozent nichts kommt noch dazu die
wanderungsgewinne von anderen also die
zahl ist schon korrekt habe ich
nachgeschaut
ich glaube dass die spd eher historische
meine these einen mann zu erregen
ich glaube dass die spd ihre historische
aufgabe gehabt hat und dass sie sich
mittelfristig aus dem parteienspektrum
verabschieden werden wir sehen momentan
zwei parteien die alle anderen vor sich
hertreiben sind die grünen auf der
linken der afg auf der rechten seite
alle richten sich danach aus das ist
praktisch der sind die beiden pole und
ich glaube die zufällig ist es keine
zufälligkeit dass die spd momentan zu
gestalten ist ich glaube es findet sich
innerhalb der spd mit den jetzigen stand
teilen keine programmatik für das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert also diesen
vorwurf hört man ja häufiger von außen
hat schon mal dass die spd gefahr laufen
könnte das schicksal anderer
sozialdemokratischer parteien in europa
zu erleiden ist das fiel den meisten
oder genügend sozialdemokraten klar was
der partei dann möglicherweise droht mal
abgesehen für die folgen der politischen
statik in deutschland wenn die spd keine
nennenswerte politische kraft mehr es
ist dass den sozialdemokraten klar dass
sie da in sie sich in großer gefahr
befinden oder wird das nach dem motto
wer also so schlimm wird's schon nicht
kommen auf die spd können wir ja kann
keiner verzichten wir werden schon
unsere rolle nach wie vor spielen wie
ist da die die stimmung in der partei
ausschließen spätestens mit dem
niedergang der der französischen
sozialisten ist jedem klar
was großen und sozialdemokratischen
parteien passieren entscheiden dass das
thema liegt liegt auf dem tisch das ist
gar keine frage ich teile nur die these
überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht dass
diese dass dies die entscheidende
politische frage und die dass das
zerwürfnis ist dass wir in den nächsten
jahren erleben würde ich sehe völlig
andere konfliktlinien ich glaube die
entscheidende frage in den nächsten
jahren die wir politisch erleben werden
ist die frage in europa national wie
wollen wir eigentlich unsere probleme
lösen was ist der der regelungs raum und
da werden wir umgruppierung prozess in
der parteienlandschaft erleben die dazu
führen dass in der tat ein teil der
union die spd und die grünen gemeinsam
dieses land in den nächsten zehn jahren
regieren müssen
das ist das wird die wirklich große
koalition das thema also die kenia
koalition wenn die wenn europa jetzt
schon ein so wichtiges thema wird ist es
ja nicht auch außerordentlich
leichtsinnig sich die zeit jetzt in den
letzten monaten so verplempert zu haben
mit diesen politischen spielchen wenn
jetzt eine wahl zum europäischen
parlament im mai 2009 10 kommt die
möglicherweise gewaltige verschiebungen
nachricht sich nicht nur durch die
wahlergebnisse in deutschland sondern
auch in anderen eu ländern absolut
sommer ja im koalitionsvertrag gleich
ein großes wichtiges kapitel europa und
jetzt sagen wir sehr teuren euro um
europas gewidmet ist und natürlich daher
muss man sagen das sind sie momentan
noch einiges schuldig geblieben aber
nichtsdestotrotz müssen nun erst mal die
innenpolitischen konflikte gelöst werden
bevor man sich um europa kümmern kann
weil so sehr die leute europa
beschäftigt die innenpolitik und ein
herr maßen internet beschäftigt sie dann
halt einfach noch mehr
wir hatten jetzt zwei leidenschaftliche
eu-befürworter zumindest mit herrn
schulz und frau merkel und weise sind da
ist nix anderes in einer fundamentalen
vertrauenskrise jetzt also man kann so
wichtig das thema europa und eu ist
damit zurzeit keine wähler massen
mobilisieren in deutschland es wäre auch
falsch wie frau merkel es tut immer
wieder nur zu sagen deutschland geht es
gut wenn wir darauf achten dass die
europäische union funktioniert ja stimmt
ist der zusammenhang nicht und b hat sie
einiges auch dazu beigetragen dass die
eu momentan in einem schlechten zustand
und ich sagen muss dass der markt ist
sehr wohl geschafft hat in einer zeit in
der auch nicht die stimmung pro eu war
mit dem thema pro europa die massen zu
mobilisieren möchte jetzt noch
schlechter da eine zustimmungsrate er
beschreibt schon glaube ich ein
zentrales risiko wir haben 70 prozent
zustimmung glaube ich zum europäischen
einigungsgedanken in deutschland 50
prozent wahlbeteiligung sogar teilweise
darunter bei europawahlen
wenn dir wenn die angst wenn die anti
europäer wenn die anti europäer
vor allen dingen mobilisiert werden im
mai und die pro europäer zu hause
bleiben
dann kann uns tatsächlich ein ergebnis
in der europawahl drohen dass europa
handlungsunfähig macht darin sehe ich
eine schon eine ernste gefahr und
aussagen wie die ist jetzt nicht so
wichtig diese wahl finde ich dann schon
gefährlich zumal sich ja in der politik
und europapolitik mit einem
verschränkten gerade in der
migrationsfrage erlebt man das ja dann
sind zwei seiten einer medaille in der
wirtschaftspolitik in der ganze reihe
von punkten
das positive was der europawahl
anbetrifft wir haben gesehen in den
umfragen dass nach der praxis
entscheidung in england eigentlich die
sensibilisierung der bürger
es war nicht nur in deutschland vor
allen dingen allerdings in deutschland
für eine europäische union viel höher
geworden ist weil der nutzen neben
europas gerade aus deutscher sicht noch
mehr so deutlich geworden ist eigentlich
eine wunderbare voraussetzung für eine
hohe wahlbeteiligung hohe
wahlbeteiligung würde sicherlich den
großen parteien eher nutzen insbesondere
der spd die früher probleme hatte die
diesmal das problem hat sie hat keine
spitzenkandidaten mehr sie muss jetzt
sozusagen ohne eigenen spitzenkandidaten
antreten
insofern leichter verluste werden ist ja
nicht völlig überraschend aber zumindest
eben dass man verhindert europaweit eben
dass rechtspopulisten hier die mehrheit
übernehmen denn das hätte wiederum
unmittelbare auswirkungen auf
innenpolitische prozesse und das wäre
natürlich fatal insofern ich glaube das
wissen auch die handelnden das geht
sogar über die koalition hinaus das eben
tatsächlich das nächste halbe jahr mit
blick auf die europawahl von enormer
bedeutung ist dass tatsächlich die
politik das wieder machen muss was eben
die bürger sozusagen in der zweiten
phase der erste der großen qualität
letzten großen koalition vermisst haben
dass sie wieder kontrolle übernehmen
dass sie wieder handeln dass sie wieder
das heft des handelns übernehmen und den
bürgern zeigen dass sie eben und was sie
zu gestalten vorhaben um so viele denken
aber viele denken doch wirklich man
wählt das europäische parlament und die
entscheidung trifft dann die europäische
kommission und ich glaube da ist eine
legitimation lücke die auch gerade von
pro europäer angeschlossen werden muss
wir tun alles ja nicht unbedingt so ist
es in dieser dies das ist ja ein vorteil
bringt aber der bisher ein militär
massentauglich zu wenig hinter helfen
dass jetzt ein deutsch anstrebt
kommissionspräsident finden lassen sie
uns noch mal zwei schritte zurückgehen
was ich hatte mir gerade gesagt hat
könnt ihr jetzt auch in bezug auf heute
ein heilsamer schock gewesen sein
noch mal den blick auf die leidtragende
angela merkel leider haben wir des
heutigen tages hat sie da jetzt vor
allen dingen deswegen auch noch eine
gewisse schonfrist weil sich nicht
wirklich einer als nachfolger als
nachfolgerin für den parteivorsitz und
später auch das kanzleramt im moment
aufdrängt dass sie da dass diese
nachfolgefrage überhaupt nicht geklärt
dass man wüsste auch gar nicht wie man
da eigentlich vorschlagen sollte dass
ihr das auch noch mal die möglichkeit
gibt doch wieder land zu gewinnen doch
wieder an macht auch zu gewinnen in
dieser neuen konstellation
also ich glaube es wird jetzt viele
davon abhängen wie sie mit dieser
veränderten ausgangssituation umgeht ob
sie tatsächlich versucht sich weiter
durch zu werkeln und zu glauben dass sie
so ein bisschen durchregieren könnte
auch in der fraktion das wird natürlich
nicht mehr funktionieren oder ob sie
auch es schafft die fraktion wieder mehr
zu umwerben die jetzt natürlich ein sehr
viel unabhängigeres machtzentrum werden
könnte es wird übrigens auch viel davon
abhängen wie sich herr brinker aus
aufstellt von dem wir noch gar nicht so
richtig und würden wissen welchen kurs
er anschlägt ist ja kein zweiter oder
ist ja kein es fällt kein zweiter jens
spahn
also es keiner der da so in die starke
konfrontation geht nichtsdestotrotz
glaube ich es wird schwierig für sie
sich zu erholen zu erholen selbst wenn
jetzt noch kein kanzlerkandidat oder
nachfolge nachfolgerin nach vorne drängt
weil natürlich heute ganz klar das
signal gegeben wurde
sie ist eigentlich zu jeder zeit an
greifbar geworden vierzehnter und am 28
oktober sind ja zwei wichtige
landtagswahlen wie es im moment aussieht
wird in bayern die csu nicht besonders
gut wegkommen und in hessen die cdu auch
nicht
eine spd möglicherweise aber noch viel
mehr getauscht wird von den wählern
was bedeutet eine eine solche erwartetes
wahlergebnis land für die bundespolitik
was die koalition wie wird sie darauf
reagieren wird sie da sozusagen als
strafe hinnehmen
das ist jetzt die quittung die wir
bekommen haben und jetzt machen wir es
besser oder hat das wieder konsequenzen
auch für die zusammenarbeit oder wird
dass die belastete die zusammenarbeit in
der koalition weiter belasten
es wird beides ist wird die
zusammenarbeit belasten weil natürlich
arbeitet es sich einfacher zusammen wenn
man erfolgreich ist
es wird aber auch weil man vereint es
alle drei parteien in der niederlage
wird es auch sozusagen die angst vor dem
bruch steigern und sofern stabilisieren
ich will noch mal ein gedankenspiel in
den raum werfen wenn heute nicht herrn
brinkhaus sondern ursula von der leyen
oder jens spahn in den ring gestiegen
werden und gewonnen hätten dann würden
wir nächste woche einen neuen
bundeskanzlers oder der bundeskanzlerin
wählen das heißt er in der tat die
machtfrage in der union ist nicht
konsequent zu ende gestellt worden und
deswegen glaube ich auch dass das
sozusagen ihre frage in die richtige
richtung weiß es gibt keinen klaren
kandidaten
es gibt keine geklärte macht situation
es gibt nicht den geborenen nachfolger
insofern wird diese situation so
instabil sie ist so stabil fortan das
heißt angela merkel sich ja eigentlich
als abschnitt vorstellen ist so zur
schrittweisen irgendwann mal legt sie
den zeitpunkt fest und dann ist alles
vorbereitet und alles wäre damit geht
das dann sozusagen relativ geräuschlos
über die bühne
das ist möglicherweise mit dem heutigen
tag nicht mehr so leicht zu machen
das war eigentlich schon vorher nicht zu
machen also ein selbstbestimmter
abschied ist eigentlich in politischen
große erzählung nicht vorgesehen
da muss man nur auf den scherz sind auch
noch nie gegeben in der prosa auf den
ruhmlosen abgang des einheitskanzler
1998 auf roten socken denken
frau merkel hätte eigentlich vor der
letzten wahl abtreten können dann hätte
sie auch noch im zenit ihres
europäischen ansehens gestanden dass nun
massiv beschädigt worden ist sie hat
sich in dieser zeit erwiesen als eine
frau die in homöopathischen dosen immer
mal wieder bereit ist rhetorische
signale auszusenden sie habe gelernt sie
habe verstanden sie haben das mehrmals
gesagt immer mehr leute bevölkerung und
nun auch in der fraktion der partei
haben den eindruck dass dies nur
kurzfristige rhetorische distanz distanz
namen sind die effektiv ohne wirkung
bleiben und wir haben glaube ich heute
gesehen dass dieses würdige ende ist
noch ein ganzes stückchen weiter was die
weiter was die würde angeht gerückt ist
aber zeitlich näher gekommen
ich habe mir die ganze zeit heute
überlegt ob es irgendwann mal eine zeit
kommen die gegner der sich immer gesagt
vor der letzten bundestagswahl wird dass
man sozusagen in würde abtreten können
mir ist allerdings kein passender
zeitpunkt ein gefallen an dem angela
merkel das hat er wirklich machen können
war der zeitpunkt vielleicht noch gar
nicht also die letzte bundestagswahl mit
sicherheit noch nicht
es wird jetzt glaube ich relativ
sukzessive passieren was ja schon
erwähnt wurde
es wird nämlich vor allem der
politikstil sich ändern ich glaube eher
das wofür eben merkel mit all ihren drei
regierungen bislang stand eben diese
sehr pragmatische zurückgenommene das
wird nicht mehr funktionieren jetzt ist
stärker führung angesagt ist stärke
diskurse angesagt auch innerhalb der
drei koalitionsparteien
sie müssen sich
tage zusammenfinden einigen auch
streiten um den richtigen kurs und ich
denke das ist gar nicht der schlechteste
für die politik was sich dann für die
union daraus ergibt wie er dann
sozusagen das ruder übernimmt das hängt
so ein bisschen auch damit zusammen wie
die union sich im parteienspektrum
entwickelt die union wird möglicherweise
wissen zwar noch nicht ganz genau woher
bringen es steht aber so ein bisschen
konservativer glaube ich wird es schon
sein und eine eigene position haben ich
glaube die cdu wird erkennbarer wieder
werden und damit möglicherweise auch die
auseinandersetzung etwas klarer zwischen
den beiden großen hat jeden fall ist die
noch immer in bewegung und eine politik
der ruhigen hand oder politik im ruhigen
fahrwasser es wahrscheinlich für viele
die das möchten ein wunschtraum da wird
relativ viel passieren wenn das genau
beobachten ich bedanke mich dass sie
daran wird da wir nicht genau wissen was
morgen der tag noch blinkt und
möglicherweise sich jetzt bei dieser
überraschenden wahl von ralph brinkhaus
noch anderes entwickelt kündige ich mag
kein thema an morgen für die phoenix
runde wir werden auf jeden fall da sein
mit einem aktuellen thema um sie über
alles was hier in berlin passiert weiter
zu informieren
bleiben sie bei phoenix
[Musik]